the city sky is frankly rather boring if
you look up at the patches of murk
between buildings you might be able to
pick out the Big Dipper
or perhaps Orion's belt but hold on look
at that murky patch again and hold out
your thumb how many stars do you think
are behind it 10 20 guess again if you
looked at that thumbnail sized patch of
sky with the Hubble Space Telescope
instead of points of light you'd see
smudges these aren't stars they're
galaxies just like our Milky Way cities
of billions of stars and more than a
thousand of them are hidden behind your
thumb the universe is bigger than you
can see from the city and even bigger
than the starry sky you can see from the
countryside this is the universe as
astrophysicists see it with more stars
than all the grains of sand on earth by
staring up at the stars at night you've
taken part in the oldest science in
human history the study of the heavens
is older than navigation agriculture
perhaps even language itself yet unlike
other sciences astronomy is purely
observational we cannot control the
parameters of our experiments from lab
benches our best technology can send man
to the moon and probes to the edge of
the solar system but these distances are
vanishingly small compared to the
yawning gulfs between stars so how can
we know so much about other galaxies
what they're made of how many there are
or that they're even there at all well
we can start with the first thing we see
when we look up at night the Stars what
we are trying to learn is their
properties what are they made of how hot
are they how massive how old how far are
they from Earth and believe it or not we
can learn all of these things simply
from the light shining in the sky
we can decipher one kind of stellar
message by turning starlight into
rainbows when you look at a rainbow on
earth you're really looking at light
from our Sun being scattered through
water droplets in the atmosphere into
all the different wavelengths that make
it up and when we study the light from
other stars we can create rainbows on
demand using not water droplets but
other specific instruments that disperse
light when we look at the scattered
light from our Sun we see something
strange dark lines in our rainbow these
lines are the characteristic
fingerprints of atoms each type of atom
in the solar atmosphere soaks up light
at specific wavelengths and the amount
of absorption depends on how many of
these atoms there are so by observing
how much light is missing at these
characteristic wavelengths we can tell
not only what elements are in the sun's
atmosphere but even their concentrations
and the same idea can be applied to
study other stars make a spectral
rainbow see what's missing and figure
out which elements are present bingo now
you know what stars are made of but we
aren't restricted to just the wavelength
that our eyes perceive consider radio
waves yes they can bring the Billboard
top 100 to your car but they can also
travel almost unimpeded through space
because they've come so far radio waves
can tell us the very early history of
the universe from just a few thousand
years after the Big Bang we can also
study the infrared light emitted by
colder objects like the gas and dust
clouds in space and the ultraviolet
light from the hot stars recently born
from those clouds studying different
wavelengths not only gives us a more
complete picture of any single object
but also different views of the universe
for this reason astrophysicists use
several different kinds of telescopes
covering the spectrum from the infrared
to the ultraviolet to the x-ray from
giant radio dishes to giant silver
mirrors to space satellites detecting
light that would be otherwise blocked by
the Earth's atmosphere
astrophysicists don't just see the
billions of stars among the billions of
galaxies in the universe they hear feel
and sense them through many channels
each revealing a different story but it
all begins with light the kind we can
see and the kind we can't want to know
the secrets of the universe just follow
the light